Why not a Tuesday evening and block 20?
Hello and welcome to the nerd writer
after dark,
the only place in the big black ether to
hear about the sexy side of high
finance.
My name is the nerd writer and I'm here
to be your guide through the titillating
seas of fiscal irresponsibility,
helping you in any way I can take it
your assets in order,
out of order,
whatever suits your financial fancy,
and I'm joined as always by my cohost,
the very mysterious original
circumstance.
How you doing tonight,
Reggie?
Just fine.
What's that?
You got there?
Read this.
My friend is a 78 Marillo by foreign
Yantais,
the same urine vintage drunk by the
senior associates at the blackstone
group.
The same year they acquired the Howard
Johnson Franchise in 1990.
Wow.
That is vintage.
I'm actually drinking a very special
bottle myself here.
Read this is an 89 Pino noir by wooden
head sent over by the board of Bain
capital.
This vintage they drank when staples
inc.
One of their very first investments went
public and it's also the wind that they
were drunk off of their gourds on when
this picture was taken.
TOnight I want to talk about one of the
sexiest figures in the nation.
If not the world.
I think you know who I mean and no,
I'm not talking about beyonce or mr.
Circumstance over there.
This is a man with both public sector
and private sector experience.
you guessed it.
I am talking about the one the only,
the irresistibly erotic,
mitt romney.
Mr romney is currently in contention for
the republican presidential nominee
touted by many as the front runner in
that race,
though a week turn out in South Carolina
has many predicting that this might
become a stripped to the waist mud
wrestling match between mit and the
improbably.
New bile newt gingrich.
Ladies I know I'm not the only one who
wants to see these two sands shirt,
but politics is the bag of a different
show here.
We are more interested in what mr romney
did before he set his sights on the oval
office and since the man himself puts
his experience at bain capital at the
forefront of his campaign,
I think it's only appropriate that we
explain and analyze that experience.
What do you think,
reggie?
I think I'm drunk now.
Those who know me know that there are a
few things that make my cherries tingle
more intensely than private equity,
but what is private equity after all?
Well,
private equity isn't asset class
consisting of equity securities in
operating companies,
not publicly traded on a stock exchange.
Well,
nerdwriter.
Hey,
that sounds like a lot of gobbledygook
to me.
Okay.
Reggie,
I think I.
I think I get your point here.
So private equity or pe used to be
called leveraged buyout or lbo.
It's the practice by which a private
equity firm like bain capital uses a
fund of money to buy out a small or
underperforming company to flip it for
profit.
It's like flip that house.
You've seen that show?
I love that show.
Okay,
so let's say that you have a company
that you want to sell,
and I'm a private equity firm.
Now the price you put on your business
is,
let's say $10.
What I'm going to do is raise 1 million
through my investors.
That's the equity.
The other 9 million I'm going to borrow
from the bank.
That's the leverage.
Okay,
so now that I have the 10 million,
I'm going to buy out your company with
$9,000,000
in debt in come in and try to streamline
all the aspects of that business,
going to make things more efficient.
The layoff,
unproductive.
Employees decrease overhead after five
years.
Let's say that I succeeded and now your
business is worth 20 million.
What I'm going to do is pay back the
bank,
gets 9 million plus interest and then
split the rest between myself and the
investors.
This is the basic model of a leveraged
buyout.
How's that?
So it looks like we have our first
caller here.
Hello,
you're on with the nerd writer.
What is your question?
I'm a long time and they love your show.
Thank you.
private equity is good or bad for the
economy seats.
I think I won't be able to run this
building from the ground reconsidering
how,
but I don't like to know what impact is.
Industry as well.
That's a great question,
mary,
and a tough one.
See these days,
romney presents himself as a job creator
recently saying we started a number of
businesses for in particular created a
hundred and 20,000
jobs as of today and there's no doubt
that private equity,
especially venture capitalism and arm of
private equity firms invest in startup
companies,
can create jobs,
especially if you make a good bet like
romney and bain capital did with an idea
for supermarket of office supplies which
later became staples.
The problem is that streamlining cutting
the fat can often mean job losses and If
the investment goes sour,
well everybody loses.
Even you married since your accountant
has invested some of your own funding.
the deal,
I'll hark capitalists like romney say
that this is unnecessary risk of the
system and maybe it is,
but the problem with the term job
creators is that job creating is never
the intended function of any of these
private equity firms.
The purpose of bain taken directly from
its website is to deliver industry
leading returns for its investors to
deliver the best returns.
Job creation and job loss are a
byproduct,
and this brings me to my central point.
It was romney and his peers at the
inception of a revolutionary new
industry called leveraged buyout or
private equity,
who helped to redefine american
business.
See these men,
a schism between the incentives of a
company's owners,
otherwise known as shareholders and the
incentives of its management.
To rectify this,
they acquired the companies themselves
via leveraged buyout,
manage them themselves,
and gave existing management and equity
stake in the company in the form of
stock or stock options.
This is the beginning of huge executive
compensation which gets the goat of
those occupy protesters.
The revolution is more clearly stated as
the total alignment in the incentives of
accompanies owners,
its board,
and its management around stock holder
value.
For more on thIs as it relates to
democracy and the recession,
see blog number four.
You can find that link in the dubliner.
I'm afraid that's all the time we have
tonight on the nerd writer after dark.
I do want to remind everyone that ridge
is a fine guitar player and he does do
all bar mitzvahs,
weddings,
and corporate functions.
I want to wish you all a good night.
I made your stocks rise in the morning
and may your competitors go utterly
bankrupt.
Hello,
issue a merry christmas.
Merry christmas.
Merry christmas from the bottom of my.